hey guys my name is Jess today it is the
eighth of September and you're changing
games but news first up a PSA for those
of you playing metal gear solid 5 you
may want to be careful to avoid a bug
which has been corrupting save files
konami has issued a warning to players
saying that the bug can be triggered if
you have quiet as a buddy character
while playing mission 29 or mission 42
the publisher are currently suggesting
that you simply avoid taking her along
on those missions while they try and
determine the cause of the bug her
release date has been revealed for The
Witcher threes first paid expansion
hearts of stone soda project red has
announced that the expansion will arrive
on octobre 13 the dev also released the
first teaser trailer for the expansion
which includes severed heads and
unlikely allies hearts of stone is said
to add another 10 hours of gameplay the
expansion introduces a number of new
narrative and gameplay elements
including broom words which will let you
experiment with different strategies and
attacks parts of stone is available in
limited boxed edition form at selected
retailers it includes a digital code for
the game a manual and to physical gwent
decks the expansion has been designed
for level 30 plus characters but you
don't have to finish the main story line
to get into it finally those bungee cord
documents are proving to be a treasure
trove of Destiny info it's been
uncovered by GamesBeat that Bungie and
Activision had planned to bring out a
new destiny game every second year up
until 29
Destiny's largest downloadable content
product with them slated to land in
September 2020 the copy of the schedule
which references destiny as a project
Tiger is out of date though get lists
the release of destiny as September of
2013 which was the original launch date
before the game was delayed it's
currently unknown whether this plan will
still go ahead over the next few years
but I guess we can just wait another 12
months and find out for ourselves let me
know down in that comment box if you
would want to play another one two three
destiny games you can add a game spot
we've got stories on Dragon's Dogma
coming to pc and the food 216 demo those
are all the good things I wanted to tell
you about today as always let me know
what mattered to you and I will catch
you tomorrow